[Music]
so Godzilla Kong the new Empire has been
preponed to the 29th of March and maybe
even earlier for a few countries you
know with the early screenings and all
of that now goel and Kong will have to
set aside their differences and team up
to fight two or more tyrants in the form
of the scar King isimo and maybe even
one or two of The Hollow Earth Kongs in
the Tyrant King Army so here in this
video we will tell you what are their
State of Affairs between these two tals
as of the present day and also three
reasons as to why or how they will team
up so let's get to
it so after the battle in Hong Kong in
GVK when Godzilla and Kong in a rare
scenario teamed up to defeat Mecha
Godzilla and W the day they also had a
last encounter after the fight a
peaceful one with Godzilla roaring and
intimidating Alpha call and the two
decided to split up with an une easy
truth this truth was nonverbally
conveyed it is that Kong gets to live
and claim the hollow Earth has his home
or even his kingdom given that
Godzilla's Reign Over the surface World
which also includes the Seas and oceans
is uninterrupted the Big G gets the top
while Kong gets the bottom tunnel
buddies this truth would be in place as
long as the status quo is held but
things that would come to pass in the
hollow Earth would change all of it and
a sequence of scenarios would lead to
the two Titans f in each other again for
Better or For
Worse so there are two paths or
anti-parallel course of events that
would push these two tant to meet up
again in a chance encounter that would
shape the outcome of the war to come and
the new Empire the first one is that
Kong will lose an initial battle to scar
King losing his ax and then later he
would gain the Power Fist you know the
Beast glove yet for some unforeseen
reason he would travel back up to the
surface maybe Chase by an army of Kongs
or maybe by shimu and a scar King
probably with the not so little mini
Kong sukko beide of him this would break
the deal causing a disturbance that
would draw Godzilla out of wherever he
is and the other anti-parallel set of
events that would push Godzilla to the
fry would be that he might lose an
initial fight or get seriously injured
in a battle against another Titan and
then he would go on to evolve in an Ice
Cavern maybe in Greenland or the Arctic
into the Ping Zilla form the fact that
he has to evolve tells us that he would
be facing a great life-ending threat
initially before meeting Kong again it
might or might not be shimu but in any
way sensing the disturbance caused by
Kong and the other Titans arrival on the
surface would draw him out of the ice
shell and then he would emerge in a new
form an evolved form ready to take on
greater
dangers so there are three reasons as to
why or how they will team up first one
for one ased by the director himself the
scaring alone is too big for either one
of them either one of the two talents to
fight alone it might either mean that
the scar king size is that large that he
could overpower them in a 1 V one combat
scenario but it could also mean that
when Adam Wingard said that scar king is
too big for them to fight alone he was
meaning that the scar King's overall
power and intellect or cutting schemes
and his army of Kongs is too big of a
threat for just one of the two hero
Titans to be able to counter alone and
then we also have the ancient Titan
shimu to count for he is rumored to be
one of the most powerful Titan if not
the most powerful therefore if they have
to team up to defeat scar King they
definitely need one another to work in
unism to fend off both of these colossal
threats that's the first reason for them
to team up they cannot do it
alone so the second reason as to why
they will team up is because of the
massive Kong Army that might or will
invade the surface World under the
command of Scar king and shimu you know
that new Empire if two massive Titans
alone are that great of a threat imagine
an army of gigantic Apes may be armed to
the teeth with the same type of weapons
as Kong had in GVK that would definitely
require more than just the atomic powers
of Godzilla or Kong with a powerless
glove to be able to deter so given a
premise that Kong will lose the battle
against the scaring and the mini Kong
suku might follow Kong to the
surface the army of Kongs will have to
follow in their Trail and would no doubt
be entering Godzilla's domain the
surface which is the surface world of
course and therefore this would be a
trigger to the Gman to react and put
things back in order maybe he would even
have to raise up the king of the
monsters tirans to fight this upcoming
War of Attrition maybe this is where the
Mothra plot comes in providing air
support to the bleed combatants and this
here is definitely a real cause for the
two main Alphas to come together or fall
alone as the poster says so thirdly
Godzilla owes a blood dead to Kong when
Godzilla first fought Kong in GVK in the
ocean he spared The Big Ape to him the
silencing of all the fleet of ships
engines was a signal enough of a
submission Godzilla here was agitated by
the gdar signals he's getting all over
the world due to apex's machinations in
the Second Battle of Hong Kong Godzilla
sensed the activation of the power
source deep in the hollow Earth and he
reacted with all his might boring a hole
through the center of the world right
onto the throne room of the Kongs this
brought Kong back up for a rematch they
both battle again and Kong lost again
with Godzilla leaving the giant ape to
die from a cardiac arrest that Godzilla
caused with a stump of his foot on
Kong's chest but then Kong was revived
and intervened in the fight between
Godzilla and Mecha Godzilla and
surprisingly saved Godzilla from being
killed by his Mecca twin Godzilla might
be an animal a Tyran but he is entirely
sentient and really intelligent like
human smart with animal Instinct smart
combined he would therefore remember
Kong's actions on that day and to him
that is a debt that is owed one that he
shall repay in the new
Empire so I speculate that when they
meet up again in the surface they would
have a short battle first maybe Kong
would submit or there could be an
outside interference by another flying
Titan which I really am hoping it would
be Mothra after this they would
encounter the two massive Titan enemies
and then they would have a showdown only
to end in the stalemate and then later
in the movie there would be part two of
the battle they would both travel down
to the hollow Earth to end the scar
King's Reign and then save the Kong
species so yeah that's it now if you
like this video then watch this other
one as well and do check out our channel
for other monsterverse content we might
just have things that you haven't seen
before like subscribe and we'll see you
in the next one take care fam